[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washa Ramsey
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America we're glad
you're here open phones at 8825
5225 that's
5225 Travis starts us off this hour in
Toledo hi Travis welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi thank you for taking my call
sure what's
up uh I have a negative balance every
month and I'm kind of trying to figure
out how to how to get positive again um
starting off kind of a little rough
every single month after bills and
everything so your your bank account is
negative every month like you're
overdrawn yep I'm overdrawn actually
almost on a weekly
basis um you know I it's funny that you
talk about this I literally just got off
a webinar about this this very thing and
at the end of the day it's probably
boiling down to budgeting issues do you
have a
budget um I've been working on trying to
do one I recently got the every dollar
app uh
premium uh because was able to track my
stuff better but yeah I'm I'm struggling
like weekly with groceries it's it's
just with a family of five it's hard to
keep it under a certain amount okay so I
want you to not try to do the budget I
want you to actually do it I want you to
go in there put the numbers in there
that's step one you and your wife yeah
have you start have you actually filled
out a budget for the
month uh no I have not I haven't been
able to figure it out yeah okay so
that's step one matter of fact um I want
you to go to everydollar.com budgeting
when this call is over and I want you to
sign up for the next webinar because if
the issue is I've got it is it you know
is it I'm not I don't have time to do it
or I'm not prioritizing the time to do
it I really want you to prioritize this
the time sit down with your wife tonight
start looking at it what's your
take-home pay uh take home is about
3,600 a month how much is your
rent uh the mortgage is 560 a month
what's your car payment uh car payment
is a little high it's 441 a
month okay and five
kids uh three kids wife that is unable
to work due to yes five people three
wife that is unable to work due to
medical issues what kind of medical
issues uh it's actually like a
hereditary degenerative uh disease where
it's actually just getting worse as time
goes on too
so okay how old are your
kiddos uh I got triplets uh 4 and a half
years old
wow okay so consumer debts kind of got
me you know how much do you
have um not including the C it's about
26,000 okay here's the thing we got to
start at the other end groceries don't
catch the slack groceries are the
thing so we're going to start with this
3600 at the top of the page you follow
me yes minus the important things first
the most important thing in your entire
budget is
food you have the money to buy food you
may not have the money to do some other
stuff but you have the money to buy food
period end of story okay so 3600 minus
food what are y'all spending on
food uh I try to keep it around 180
bucks a week but I mean it's usually 180
bucks to 220 how often do you eat out
how often do you eat
out um
maybe once a week but it's just me for
lunch when I'm able to pack I am going
to a trade school at night it's either
lunch or dinner I go three nights a week
um okay all right so so if we take um
800 bucks 700 bucks for your budget for
food right for a month for a month that
leaves us
$2,900 so you can buy food food's first
you got me yes I don't care if you pay
anybody else you feed your family you
follow me all right second thing is we
pay $550 for shelter
done right yep and then we pay the light
bill and the water bill so we're warm
we're fed and we're
dry okay this is survival first you
following me yes uh we may not keep the
stupid car cuz it's freaking out of
control if we can't come up with a way
to get it paid off soon it's got to go
but for now we're going to pay the car
payment too food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities are basic
necessities of life we call those the
four walls you do the four walls before
you do anything else everyone else and
let me tell you who's at the bottom of
the freaking list student loan how big's
a student loan I don't have one thank
you know who's right at the bottom next
to them stupid credit card companies cuz
you know what they can do if you don't
pay them nothing except destroy your
credit and Sue eventually 8 years from
now but we're going to take care of them
before we get there okay they're at the
bottom of the page so let me just tell
you your emotional state and your sense
of control over your destiny changes
when your family is fed the lights and
water are paid and the mortgage is paid
and you you are in a different place
emotionally and spiritually the rest of
it's just a stupid game I'm behind
on okay but right now it feels like life
or death cuz you've got groceries as the
last thing not the first
thing yes by the time I pay groceries
I'm overdraft no by the time you pay
MasterCard Oh wait we're not going to go
into overdrift so we're not paying
MasterCard screw them okay for this
month and then we've got to adjust our
income now you got to get your income up
dude what are you gonna do to get your
income up it it it goes up progressively
every uh every six months as long as I
keep up my uh my apprenticeship and
everything so you got you got six months
Ah hell then ahead what are we going to
do in the short term to get it
up um you're going to stade school three
nights a week what are we doing on those
other nights cuz you're about to do some
more work dude your family's hungry
homework and doing whatever I can yeah
around the house housework and
everything yeah you're going to probably
not be doing as much of that the laundry
May pile up a little bit because you got
to go make some money cuz 3600 bucks is
tough
M so the way you the way you get this
straight Side Up is you first take care
of necessities and then two you get over
the top of it and we're going to cut
expenses and add income and that creates
margin and that will get you under
control Travis so you you do have a very
tight tight tough
situation so something's got to go out
of the expense lines and something's got
to come up quickly in the income side
because you know you know it's not easy
you got a really nice low house payment
it's the best thing in this whole story
right
now
so you got you got a fixable situation
but the faster you get the income up and
the out go down the faster the Pain's
going to leave okay does that make sense
to you yeah absolutely I was just
nervous about missing credit card
payments and stuff I want to give you
permission to feed your children before
you pay MasterCard yeah I understand
okay when you get that straight in your
head all of a sudden it changes
everything because if everybody's fed
and the lights are done and the water's
paid and and the house payments paid I
mean we we live to fight another day but
if we pay MasterCard and then we don't
have enough money to feed the triplets
dad gum that's not fun been there done
that that terrorizes your butt doesn't
it yes it does been there done that
every dollar.com budgeting sign up for
one of Jade's webinar she'll walk you
through what we just did this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need y refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
88255 225 Andy is in bismar North Dakota
hi Andy welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave and Jade how how y'all
doing better than we deserve what's
up well see my question today is where
do
um thinking funds land and the baby
steps um I guess I'm currently on baby
step
2 um and so I have my emergency fund of
$1,000 um and you know I have a house
and in need of you know a new washer a
new toilet I mean I'm I'm able to make
buy when you say you need it okay here's
here's the way I think of it and Bab
maybe step two I want all the money I
can possibly to go to mors my Deb
Snowball right and so if I'm kind of
packing it all away and sinking funds it
puts less to my snowball so I'm moving
slower in my mind and then you don't
forget You' still got the, saved so
washer dryer what was the other thing
you said toilet toilet if there's any
way that you can kind of cash flow a
quick quick repair on the toilet or just
kind of keep things running I would do
that as opposed to backing away more
money to to replace the washer that
hasn't even broken down yet does that
make sense that's what I would do I
would do no home repair sinking funds
while you're in baby step
two okay I would just I would just cash
flow what cash flow
emergencies so if the if the washer goes
out repair it or buy a different one
used right uh if the toilet goes out
call you know fix the toilet obviously
you got to have that thing running so uh
but I mean you cash flow those
emergencies only everything else Waits
until after
and you might be surprised how long flat
tire that doesn't get me to work or yeah
flat tire you you can cash flow that or
take that out of the Thousand then re
refund the Thousand either one but yeah
we're not we're not doing a big car
repair sinking fund you don't need
$3,000 in your car repair syncing fund
while you got $10,000 in credit card
debt exactly and you might be surprised
like you know the washer could go on for
far longer than you thought you know the
toilet could be working maybe it runs or
maybe it doesn't you know do what you
want it to do but if it's getting the
job done I found like a hack on YouTube
of all that that makes it run but it's
not like super efficient yeah that's
fine that's okay yeah I I put a little a
a little black tar stuff on my roof
where it was
leaking when I was in baby step 2 oh
yeah because it was running down through
the light fixture and dripping on the
kitchen table and you know the
electricity water thing doesn't mix so
didn't think I want to keep doing that
so I just smeared some stuff up there
that was about $8 and then I put the
$6,000 roof on the house which it
desperately needed after we were done
with baby step
2 oh cool yeah but yeah I I you know I
discovered you guys back in April and I
really needed you all the most and uh um
got signed up for FPU and got the
premium version of every dollar and has
helped me so much I'm glad money for the
months now I I'll add one other thing
because of the the the season that we're
in if you have family you are going to
do something for
Christmas you need to go ahead and
decide what that is and put that aside
cuz that one will sneak up on you and
bite you that's a good point Dave okay
that's that's something we're going to
do talk to him about it and uh know we
we have a plan for him and he's he's
happy I'm happy okay made good deal so
yeah we take care of the kiddos and
especially the little ones and you know
a little a little something for each
other is fine that's not not the end of
the world but we we're not doing $3,000
Christmases when we're broke people so
you know I mean you're we're going to
cut this down we're going to have a plan
and we need set that aside so it doesn't
sneak up on you and bite you cuz it's
it's much Christmas is much more fun if
you do it with a plan absolutely and you
know somehow people think chaos is and
is helps your
generosity oh because they think that
they want to just be able to go out and
spend on a wh and it's just like I'm
it's not like coming from the heart if
I'm doing it from a plan it's like no
you're being child not a grownup if
you're you know it's just you know it is
coming from the heart yeah and you're
probably going to get big better gifts
if you sit down and plan for it hello
because you're going to have a plan
you're not going to just go oh that's on
sale that looks good I'll get that
seldom do you get the best price on
impulse that's the truth you know there
you go I mean you make these dollars
stretch and we start laying out a
Christmas budget and um I talked to my
old friend Santa Claus and he said the
way to do a Christmas budget is make a
list and check it twice then put a
dollar amount beside
person so what you're saying so you know
this is what I'm spending on this is
this is and and George George camel and
I were talking about this the other day
and he said so what's beside my name I
said $5 he said so I'm a $5 friend
$5 nothing actually is beside George's
name technically I pay him a paycheck he
needs to just smile but anyway but the
uh but but seriously but I mean you know
he goes okay so I can I can decide
you're a $5 friend or you're $25 mother
or you're a whatever right you just yeah
I'm sorry but you are putting a value on
which who's going to get why cuz you're
going to spend more on certain family
members than you're on others you should
spend more on the little kids than on
you know the the uh Uncle that's
generally drunk and not there anyway you
know and so on right so I mean you it
should be it should be off right I think
so well that's your take on it do you
want to know my take on it yeah let's
heare your take everybody has that
person or those people that every year
they feel obligation like I've got to
get so and so gift or uh if I don't get
she gets me something and if I don't get
I just say permission to say no yeah and
you know a preemptive no is a good idea
a preemptive no is a good idea hey you
know what I'm on a budget I want to let
you know please don't get me anything
cuz I'm not getting you yes just tell
people changed it changed everything mic
dropped or do that thing where it's like
uh if you have a big family we used to
do this you put everybody's name and
everybody draws one name instead of
getting you know gifts for 12 people and
the cousins and Grand kid we were in
bankruptcy we went to Sharon's family
she's got five brothers and sisters all
married all with kids 13 grandkids on
that side what eight adults 10 adults
right and then Mom and Dad and they're
all great people yeah but we went in at
Thanksgiving we went hey guys um
announcement we're broke yep uh we're
not buying every by gifts this year mhm
we are opting to draw names hope you'll
draw one with us yep and they
went yes we all hate it let's change it
and there was like waiting on somebody
to First say it now we did take the
little kids all the little grand kids
that were under a certain age they could
just stay in the general General gift
pool but the adults you know you buy
your brother-in-law a tie I mean come on
well that worked out good for you cuz I
had some family members who will rame
remain nameless who were like oh you're
ruin it you're ruining it for you're
messing up Christmas and I was like no
I'm not you don't look like the Grinch
no you just don't look like I'm not a
real Grinch but when it's time to get
debt-free and when it's time to lay out
those boundaries then it's listen
adulthood is different from Grinch
that's right grinching is you're just
tight fisted for no parent parent reason
and you end up buying let's be honest
when you don't have the money to spend
and you feel like you have to stretch
and buy everybody something you end up
giving crappy gifts that's true let's be
honest about that I'd rather give one or
two really nice gifts for the people who
should be on the list than stretching
myself thin and getting everybody a $5
gift that I got at I don't know so go
ahead I mean this is it's early to talk
about this but you need to plan it so
let's make a list check it twice put a
dollar amount beside it total up the
dollar amount that's your Christmas
budget if you don't like your Christmas
budget go back and lower the dollar
amounts or take some people off the list
yep and then just give them the old uh
list notification removal thing or yeah
or you could I love this this is me I do
the cheapest I will go in the kitchen
and I will bake cookies a cookie and I
will put them in a nice little tin and
it's about so you're not even a $5
friend you're just a cookie friend I'm a
cookie friend that's right people love
that love things that you can eat i'
rather have it than the $5 I'm just
saying look no one wants another bad
smelling candle no one wants another
soap with a ribbon on it that you're
never going to use oh that's the guest
soap nobody wants that they don't want a
candle I can't tell you how when we
moved how many I got in one cabinet and
I opened it up and I'm like
Sharon and she said they're all gifts
and I'm like this is the number of
scented candles that were in the Ramsay
house that had never been lit it was
like we had a collection of every brand
and every scent we could have opened our
own little store yep and um I was just
disgusted and I should have sold him or
something but I just tossed him yeah it
was just like God this is just disgust
it's like what yes no more no more my my
friends the minimalists would have been
happy with me I just chunk the candles
yeah just toss them out too many things
that don't bring what's the other lady
don't bring me joy right that's right
Mar Marie Marie condo yeah this is the
ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
Sha
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
[Applause]
more
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services once the kids are back in
school it's hard to find time for Home
Maintenance but neighborly is your
source for home repair experts like
Precision Door Service drier vent wizard
download the neighborly app today to be
ready for All Seasons all right today's
question comes from Tim in Louisiana he
says I have about $56,000 and credit
card debt I'm being sued by one of my
creditors for two credit cards totaling
$30,000 the other credit card is one
month late and another two months late I
lost my full-time job in January of 2022
due to medical issues my income at the
moment is $1,800 per month I'm currently
interviewing for a full-time job I do
not have the funds to afford a lawyer to
litigate the cases neither do I have the
money for a lump sum the lawyers I've
contacted recommended Chapter 7
bankruptcy do you have any
suggestions man oh man uh you know
you've got a tough situation you've got
the $56,000 in credit card debt and to
make it worse you already knew it was
bad but now they're suing you and you
feel like you're under the gun and you
know you're feeling forced to make a lot
of changes right now in the moment um
I'm not in your shoes but if I
were I would really just take your time
and just take a deep breath for a moment
because yeah you're being sued but
nothing is happening today like in this
moment they're not coming to get you
they're not throwing you in jail so
you've got a couple of things hopeful
that are taking place you've got a
full-time job interview that's around
the corner that's good I want you to
keep applying to other places because I
want you to have a couple of job
interviews coming up in case one of them
doesn't pan out so right now thing one
is let's get money coming in keep
applying for jobs keep interviewing
because once you get money coming in
suddenly you're going to be able to go
okay I have options I can start to see a
light at the end of the tunnel
um I would not pay a lawyer yet I would
A1 get income in get your job coming up
it says you had a medical issue but it
sounds like it was kind of a one-off
thing considering that you're
interviewing for full-time jobs again so
yeah I'm not going to hire a lawyer just
yet I am not going to fire file for
bankruptcy just yet uh you didn't say
what you were making before and what you
plan on making in the future let's
pretend that it's somewhere around the
Medan income let's pretend it's
somewhere between 50 and
67,000 if that's the boat if that's
where you're going to be you're going to
be just fine and it's going to take you
around average like the folks that we
talk to every day it's probably going to
take you around 2 2 and a half years to
pay this off and then this is going to
be something that was in your rear view
you got in a really scary situation you
climbed your way out you were patient
you didn't freak out just because you're
getting letters and notices and the
they're supposed they're trying to freak
you out they want you freaked out J
Jade's exactly right um okay they've
sued
you 100% of the time you're going to
lose the
lawsuit because it's not based on
whether you're a good person it's based
on you had a bill to pay and you didn't
pay it you lose mhm you can hire a
lawyer if you want to hire a lawyer but
it's a waste of money you still lose
you're going to lose the lawsuit okay
then you're going to have what's called
a
judgment and then if decide to execute
on the Judgment that will be anywhere
from two years or two months from now to
never okay it typically is never with
credit card companies but if they decide
to execute on it that is when they would
garnish of your wages and that's a
minimum of two months from the date of
the court date when you lose the lawsuit
okay so the judgment is final on the
court date or it's final 30 days later
depending on the state that you're in
and then after that they can sit and
another 30 days and wait and if you
don't do anything the fact that you've
gotten a judgment against you then they
can execute on the Judgment which would
they be able to scarf a bank account
they would be able to put a lean on your
home in some states they would be able
to uh garnish your wages and that's
executing on a judgment again nine out
of 10 times credit card companies don't
do that ever they just take the Judgment
lean and it's sitting there and then
someday you wake up and you're able to
pay and you call them back and you work
out a deal which is actually what's
going to happen here my point is it's
going to drag out um long enough that
you should get your income back up you
should have already done that by now
you're late well yeah I and so let's get
with it let's get that income back up
and as as Jade said now when the income
comes up call the attorney that took the
Judgment lean and negotiate a settlement
plan a lump sum I owe you
$30,000 or I owe you 15 and 15 um I can
pay you 20 cents on the dollar for that
and a lump sum and if you saved up 5,000
bucks you can probably settle that
$30,000 judgment lean with them on a
credit card debt so you save up the
money and you settle the debt and then
you move on with your life but you got
to get your income up to be able to do
all this 1,800 bucks a year after you
got after you lost the job due to
Medical um if your medical if your
health has recovered you need to get
back to work hardcore like jobs by the
end of the week and 16 more places to
apply for full-time work well he's only
working parttime he's only making $1,800
a month that means before like it
doesn't matter what happens with these
interviews you need to be getting
something else tomorrow like you can
work atonal you need to be working 80
hours a week yeah you can work at
McDonald's and make more than that
working fulltime you can work at UPS is
hiring uh FedEx is hiring for the for
the Christmas rush yes everybody's
hiring it's $20 an hour it's a lot more
than 1,800
bucks2 go to work is a great place to go
when you're broke to work and that's
where you that's your deal you're going
to have to create some income and then
when you create that income you'll be
able to settle this judgment in a
lumpsum settlement with the attorney in
writing long before they get around to
executing on the Judgment that is going
to occur you're going to have a judgment
you're going to lose the lawsuit yeah
it's not even worth hiring don't hire a
lawyer don't hire a lawyer it's a waste
of money and you're not bankrupt you
just don't have an income mhm because
you can solve all of this for 10 or
15,000 bucks yeah and so go get a lot of
income stack some cash and clean this up
you're not bankrupt you don't have an
income mhm Bankruptcy Court does not
create income people it doesn't take
1,800 and make it livable it's not
livable that's not a living wage and
that's what I want to camp out just for
a little bit longer something tells me I
I I assumed before that maybe he was
making somewhere around median income
but I don't think so because if you're
racking up 56,000 in credit card debt
it's because you're most likely I'm not
saying he is but you might be using
credit cards to float a low core income
it could be it could be and and it could
be just straight up what a lot of people
did like I did it was just
irresponsibility yeah that's true so I
mean I I don't know but either way
stacking cash solves it that's fact and
so go make the most money you've ever
made in your life by working the most
hours you've ever worked in your life
consecutively don't worry you won't die
from overwork right before you die
you'll pass out don't worry about it go
to work go work your tail end off off
and create some money and I've done it
Jade's done it uh we're neither one of
us afraid to do anything that is legal
and moral to go make money we've both
done it and it's what it takes to get
your family and your situation out of a
ditch man Rebecca's in Philadelphia hi
Rebecca welcome to the ramsy
show hi thanks for having me sure what's
up so I have a little bit of a it's not
an issue it's more of a blessing I guess
um I started the business in 2020 um and
I have about $2 million in the bank um
single when that happens single
mom single mom my whole life um scraped
by and this is all new to me did you
sell the
business no I'm still it's still
going making bank wow what kind of
business is it well I hate to no don't
say it but no no no no no no it not that
way it's just due to coid um the co
vaccines I do billing for doctor's
offices hm so all these all these
vaccines what we do is we do the medical
billing and we take a percentage of
their revenue yeah of course the
pandemic
andick um blew up no no pun intended
yeah wow yeah no pun intended okay so so
that the number one this is probably not
going to be the rest of your
life no okay so you you need to be
looking at your business model on what I
can do to um diversify my sources of
income because this one's not forever
agreed agree and I'm not old I'm not
anywhere near retirement age and yeah
but I'm just saying if you're going to
run a business let's run it with a model
that accepts that this is not the future
then the second thing is what to do with
the 2.1 million way to go hey we want to
give you Financial pece University we'll
show you with the baby steps exactly
what to do with it we're going to pay
off your house we're going to pay off
all your debt uh we're going to enjoy
some of it we're going to be generous
with some of it and we're going to
invest some of it for the future and
we'll show you how to do everything bit
of that for free our gift to you to say
way to
[Music]
go hey folks Dr John deloney here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time they become healthy
habits like choosing to slow down and
make time for a daily practice of prayer
and meditation one thing that has helped
me with a daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you 3 months free to get
started that's 3 months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling Hall
makes it easy to practice mindfulness
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and choose peace remember halow is
giving you 90 days free imagine the
peaceful habits you can establish in 90
days go to hall.com Ramsey today and
follow the simple prompts to start your
free 90-day trial
that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey thank you for Jo morning US
America we appreciate you joining us
open phones at
225 kayn is with us in Las Vegas Hi
kayln how are
you I'm good thank you how are you guys
better than we deserve what's
up um so I'm trying to decide if I
should go back to school for my
bachelor's degree I have an Associates
currently or if I should pay down a home
renovation loan that my husband and I
took out H what's making you decide to
go back to school like what's the
purpose in
that so um to give you guys a little bit
of background uh we followed the baby
steps um skipping number five because we
didn't have children at the time and we
were able to get to number six and pay
off our home um so we decided
to basically put our entire life of
having kids on hold until then um once
we paid off our home timing worked out
Kind of Perfect because we're both
obsessive planners we had our daughter
and that was last year so it was a total
of
$127,000 in 30 months total that we paid
off okay we had her and I quit my job um
I have an associates degree but I wasn't
using it I was just working dead end at
admin jobs and I've been looking for my
calling for some time and I feel like I
found it in frontend developing but I
want to have that degree and be able to
make more money for my family and you
don't need a foure degree to be a
front-end
developer fair enough but through
through talking through my community of
people that I know who who do work in
this field they said it it gives you the
option to be picky basically bull where
if you go to a you don't buy it okay no
I got I got 400 folks working in our
Tech Team I got front- end developers
backend developers platform architect
people all over this building almost
none of them have a 4-year degree
and believe me getting on it Ramsay's
hard yeah yeah I I bet um so the I guess
in that case you guys don't think I
should go to school at all for this
because it's going to cost 16 to
$18,000 for my degree to be finished I
think you should now I think you should
get the certification you need to do the
job you want to do but to Echo what Dave
said it's not necessarily a four-year
degree maybe it's another program
specifically designed you may you may
need to get some of your Microsoft
search you may need to do some code
School M and code school could be as
much as 10 grand but uh if you're if
you're not up on your
skills and that's kind of what I'm
obviously that is a path I definitely
can pursue I just I'm conc you have to
do that anyway because a four-year
degree doesn't teach you to write
code and you can't be a front-end
developer if you can't write code and
whatever you learn in your fourth year
degree is going to be it's going to be
changed you know that that that field is
constantly changing and you're
constantly having to update your
education
yeah if your goal is to write code
you've got to learn to write
code my my biggest concern that I'm
having though is I'm working part-time
from home remote and taking care of our
daughter I'm not able to produce a full
salary right now and we do have our
house paid off we we don't have any debt
literally none other than the renovation
loan how much is know if I should uh
$80,000 and we we do have the ability to
pay it over time obviously we don't want
to do that because
higher uh 80,000 okay I would just put
that at your baby I would check you know
that's the only debt you have it's a
mortgage on your house I would call that
your baby step six MH and so yeah I'm
going to school and I'm going to pay
cash for school um because that's what
you want to do but I am
challenging strongly your
presuppositions I think you're wrong I
agree okay I mean I I got a bunch of
what you're talking about working here
and I and I hired them I mean I didn't
personally hire them but I the
leadership team that that I lead hired
them and uh you know I've got a whole
building full of tech people half our
dead gun product line three4 of our
product Line's digital so um you know
it's just it's part of what we do every
day here I mean think about what it
takes just to support every dollar if
nothing else the number of front end
backend creatives everything else on
that is incredible so um the uh but you
know and you know we Support bethl Tech
on because for 10 grand you can learn
the right code you can come out there
you're Dev one or Dev two coming out the
door of that place and it's 10 grand if
you want to write code now if you want
to be a CTO you may want to be a
four-year degree if you want to
specialize in web security and you want
to learn all the different nuances of
that that's not code that's not a
front-end developer then you might want
a four-year degree Information Systems
is not a bad degree but it is not
necessary to write front-end backend
code uh or to be proficient in uh Ruby
on Rails or whatever it is you're the
people you're working with a writing in
and so um you know that's what matters
is can you can you write the code that
makes the Thing dance and and that's
syntax that's all that is and and it's a
process to learn like learning another
language and um so now you know
everything I know about it which is
almost nothing but but I I do write the
checks for these people's pay and and I
do know that we don't require them to
have a 4year degree and we went oh we're
going to select you you're not real good
at code but you have a four-year degree
over the guy who can write Cod so fast
it makes your cross no we're going with
the you know the dev over your dadum
4year degree every stinking time with
proven code skills yeah our our career
Coach Ken Coleman talks about that all
the time and he'd probably suggest you
go to bethl tech.com Kin Coleman and see
what they offer it's not your typical
fouryear degree program no and it's just
what probably just what she's looking
for so again it if your goal is what you
said to be front end you do not I just a
100% sure I'm an employer of a bunch of
them again that that you don't need that
yeah but if you've got a different goal
that's nuanced in I want to enter
through the front-end developer then you
know okay you might need to have that
information system's foure degree it it
gives you it doesn't it doesn't even
give you the permission to play it's not
table Stakes it's just
um knowledge base it gives it gives you
because knowledge is the currency you're
after and you know what that's a good
jumping off point let's just do a Dave
Jade rant here uh the student whole
student loan debacle out there and it's
not her she's not doing this at all but
this one of the things we've discovered
in fighting against these student loans
and their restarting and everything else
is the core issue is that Americans got
lied to for the last 50 years mhm we
told our every generation that you had
to get a college degree to be successful
that was born in and of course that's
bull crap absolutely that was born and
any college degree will make you
successful you get a degree in
left-handed puppetry German POA history
and then America owes you a living no
they don't you're going to be a barista
yeah okay that's dumb so don't go get a
stupid useless degree well Shame Shame
on shame on parents and shame on
guidance counselors for making things
like Community College yeah and the and
the trades seem like a lower option
right because when I was in school if
you said you were back then it was
called VA state if you said you were
going to VA State people looked at you
and went oh you just didn't make the big
team you're on the junior pro look at
that and and a lot of that parents a lot
of that is parents wanting to be able to
say my kid goes to Berkeley College of
Music my kid goes to FSU my kid go like
we get a lot of Pride out of that and at
what cost yeah a lot so the thing that
that was the the problem was the lie
like so many good lies was based in 98%
truth get a college degree and you'll be
more successful so that's a lie but the
98% truth that's inside of that is get
more knowledge that's right you
knowledge is the currency of the culture
and in her case knowledge is her
currency it's not the degree yeah it's
not permission to play it's not you can
be more picky it's knowledge and it
knowledge always getting knowledge the
rest of your life is mandatory ex
exactly but we have this thing of I get
my foure degree and I'm done and I'll
watch Netflix the rest of my life yeah
no it doesn't work like that no and you
know everything about Tiger King and
nothing else so now you continuous
learning the continually GA The
Continuous Gathering of knowledge
knowledge is the currency of successful
people you can spend knowledge and
become successful more knowledge in the
proper way that has use to the society
creates more financial and societ
success relational success so gather
knowledge don't gather degrees some
people gather more degrees than a
thermometer and they have no knowledge
worse than that they have no
wisdom and and then they're useless to
the culture yeah and $260,000 in $280
million and credit card student loan
debt yeah so and and try to get the
knowledge that people care about you can
and in her in her case get the knowledge
that causes you to get the job you
want and make sure you're getting the
right thing because that's another one
those pieces of the LIE this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show hey what's up guys it's Jade if you
love the show and want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing Rel relationships Jade washaw
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at8
825-5222
55225 Allison is with us in Salt Lake
City hi Allison welcome to the ramsy
show thank you it's a pleasure to speak
with you guys you too what's
up uh my question is about syncing funds
and logistically where do you keep that
money that you are setting aside for Big
Ticket items do you keep it all in your
checking account or do you have like 10
different little savings accounts I
would not do 10 different savings
accounts or keep it with my normal
checking account balance you could do it
one of two ways you could either pull it
out and put it in cash envelopes and
just kind of have those put them in your
safe or put them you know wherever you
keep safe money in the house or um I'll
be honest I like to do my savings
accounts in online banks and a lot lot
of them the one I use you can kind of
have one account but you can drop it
into different buckets and so let's say
you've got you know you've saved up
$10,000 and you've got 2,000 of it as a
new lawn mower and 3,000 of it you know
you can name it off in buckets so you
can see and whenever you automate money
over there you can let it you know go
into whatever bucket for your uh syncing
fund that it needs to go into so that's
how I do it yeah we we keep two accounts
for purposes of this one is for your
emergency fund it should be completely
separate and disconnected from
everything mhm no uh Auto overdraft
protection on your emergency fund no ATM
access on your emergency fund you don't
have real life emergencies that are
instant you do have real life impulses
that are instant so you keep your
emergency fund where it's hard to get to
then I kept a separate checking account
and then like Jade said I just keep
buckets on it uh there's actually a form
in if you wanted to use oldfashioned
paper forms there's a form in the back
of the Total Money Makeover book called
the break down of savings form and all
that is is just like okay there's
$10,000 in this miscellaneous sying fund
savings account that's not emergencies
okay and of that $5,000 is a car $2,000
is furniture replacement and U $1,000 is
Christmas and it adds up to $110,000 you
see what I'm doing so it's it's just
like she said it's bucketed out uh and
it's a separate account if you say said
large ticket items I would use a bank I
wouldn't use envelopes on large ticket
items if you got something that's a
couple hundred bucks here or there yeah
envelopes are great for
that okay so you're just saying maybe
when I'm doing my budget if I say all
right we've got a total of $700 that
were putting into various thinking funds
let me send that $700 to a totally
separate online bank because I know my
little local bank that I use it's like
really high maintenance to go in and set
up different accounts they don't have
find one that's not how find one that's
got the bucket feature to it like she's
talking about it just makes it easier
but if you want to just it's a scratch
Pad it's 10 items how many people how
many different sinking funds are going
to be combined
there well I know it depends on how well
I mean you're not going to do $50 ones
$50 ones are going in a envelope I'm not
going to screw with it for that what you
could do this is what you could do do
you have every
dollar um I have I I'll be honest I've
been binge listening lately and I've
been motivated to budget which is what
is getting me started on this I'm
currently like dating the reason I say
that is because let's say you have $700
that that's your extra that's going
towards various seeking funds in essence
it's going to One account but on every
dollar you can create a separate fund
for each of them and that'll keep track
of how much you have going to a you know
car repair how much you have going
towards a new sync how much you have
it'll keep track of it monthly that way
you don't have to fool with the bank to
do that you don't have to have it on
paper it's there within your budget and
then but where would the money
physically be sitting it physically be
going it'll physically go to whatever
savings account you set up whether so
you would have to set up a savings yeah
whether that's savings account for my
emergency F yeah but if you want to be a
if you want to be able to see at a
glance if you want to be able to see at
a glance how much do I have for the
washer how much do I have for the new
car you'll be able to see that on every
dollar because it'll keep that running
total in your fund yeah it'll help you
it'll give you sinking fund totals it
gives you the breakdown of Sal yeah and
so but if you you
need it's preferable and the easiest to
have a a savings account that you can
attach to your checking account move the
money from your checking account that's
$700 into there and then bucket it $50
to that $100 to that $150 to that and
every dollar will help you keep that
breakdown and uh yeah I would jump in
and use that that's one of the every
dollar is just so robust it'll help you
get this done all right Stacy's with us
in Los Angeles hi Stacy how are you
hi Dave hi Jay thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up so my
husband and I were in baby steps four
five and six and we would like to know
if it would be unwise to sell our house
to move or sell our house and downsize
into a condo to be in a better
area what would be unwise about
that well I don't know I've always lived
in this area where we're at and so
jumping from this city to the next it
just seems I don't know we've just never
done it so is it the city aspect or that
you're going to a smaller
home no it's the city aspect
okay so right now where we live we love
our house we love our school but once
you leave our
house um you know we're driving down the
road and we're you know to get to my
daughter's gymnastics we drive by a
shrip club and the homeless situation is
getting kind of out of control and we
just kind of want to be in an area
eventually um where you know it's new
and safe and I I just I you want to live
in a better neighborhood I don't think
there's anything wrong with that what's
wrong with that is that I just I just
wasn't sure if I'm just you know not
being grateful or content I also want to
know if I'm just have one of these crazy
ideas again or should we just stay put
well are you are you downsizing are you
spending less money and getting less
home so it would be downsizing mortgage
wise we would like to stay in the 25% of
our take-home pay um so we would have to
downsize into a condo and that's what
the part is that dumb is that dumb to do
when you're living in a home with a good
school but everything else around you is
kind of let me help you if everything
else around there's gone then pretty
soon the school's going to go too that's
right I know well I mean that's reality
isn't it yeah yeah no that's probably
what's going to happen it kind of seems
like you have in your mind this picture
of what life is supposed to look like
and you're going in another Direction
you're going no this is this is what
happiness looks like for us happiness
for us is being in this area it doesn't
matter what the size house is it doesn't
matter these are the things that make us
happy and it sounds like you're kind of
budding that up against what culture has
told you and I think that if you've
decided hey you're fine living in a
smaller residence that's your
prerogative I grew I grew up in a 1,000
ft home I'm not mad at my parents I
wasn't abused or mistreated but I'm not
required to live in a 1,000 ft home in
order to not be a
snob I cannot be a snob and live in a
big butt house M it's a the size of your
house doesn't determine whether you're a
snob yeah you're not being ungrateful
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
/
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
88255 225 Graham is in Boston hi Graham
welcome to the Ramsey Show thanks so
much Dave and Jade we it's really an
honor to speak with both you we've been
listening and uh you know on your
program for the last 20 years um we paid
off um you know $21,000 in 18 months as
a result and just thank you so much my
question has to do with my my wife and I
are considering uh going on the missions
field and we're very curious your your
guidance and Counsel on how we should
prepare financially for
that okay how prepared are you
financially for that well we're we're in
baby steps four five and six um we
currently have about a an annual salary
of about $250 to
$300,000 um and we're not sure the
timing of when we would go so we're just
curious about what we should be looking
to try and do before we we end up going
on the
field okay is the timing sooner or later
you're talking about 10 years from now
uh when the kids are grown and gone
you're talking about uh you've
established a a net worth and you'll
live out of that instead of raising
funds or are you talking about 10 months
from now no we're probably looking more
towards 5 to 10 years from now okay all
right that helps set the table so you
make really good money in what field
um my wife um works for the government
and I work as a management consulting
for a a just a big firm okay so based on
your projections where will you be uh
you you should have the house paid off
and have a pretty substantial net worth
in 5 to 10 year shouldn't you that
that's the plan y we we currently about
a $500,000 net worth but yeah yeah we
would be looking to try and do that yeah
I mean you would you're four five and
six so you'd pay off the house and um it
hypothetical if you're going to stay on
the mission field you're not going to
need the house so that would add to the
pile of money that you would live out of
so um I mean the way I view it and
there's a a a vast array
of views on missionary work and how it's
funded around Christianity for sure uh
the way I look at this whole thing is
pretty simplistically I don't own
anything I am a Christian God owns it I
manage it for him if he's asking me to
go on the mission field and use his
money to do that boom I'm doing it facts
okay and so whatever pile of money I
have or assets I have are for his use
and if you determine his use in your
call Life as a call to the mission field
for a number of years then if you're
going to be there three or four years
you're going to sell your house well I
wanted to ask that question how long do
you
foresee doing
this well I mean we'll we'll go until
the Lord calls us to to not but I mean
we're we're also not entirely sure if
we'd go support raising you we try to
start a business you know and and try to
prepare and so that may add in what what
sort of capital we want to raise prior
to going but
yeah let's pretend you got a million and
a half dollars with a paid off including
paid off house just for the fun of it
which is possible making 250 okay in 5
to 10 years all right if you had that
just in a pile in a mutual fund and it
makes 10% it makes $150,000 a year
you're you're you're self-funded in
perpetuation you follow me yeah I do
yeah I guess part of my our question is
my wife's parents you know served on the
field for 20 22 25 years you know as we
prepare to potentially have to support
them with their limited retirement
options should we add that calculation
in like should we be trying to set aside
to help them or I mean I know that's
part of the overall picture and but I
mean that that's sort of a how do we
think about there's going to be a need
to potentially have that additional
expense that we have to take care of as
well well you're you're supporting two
missionaries one that didn't have
support and you yeah and so now we're
supporting two families out of this
150,000 and I guess that depends on how
you want to live on the field and where
which country you're in what the
lifestyle entails and what they need
living back here you know and what they
need but I mean if if you can live on 75
and they can live on 75 and your nest
eggs creating 150 you're still in
perpetuation agreed
yeah oh yeah so I mean that's the way
you just work it out and go okay what
does Mom and Dad need I'll guarantee you
they're not used to living very high on
the hog agreed right yes they they they
were they probably don't have hugely
opulent expectations these are probably
wonderfully modest humble
people that's correct they are yeah and
if and depending on which area of the
world you're in your cost of living may
be Zippo you know yeah it may not be
much I don't know how what whe you're
talking about I don't know what country
you're talking about a developing
country or whatever but uh you can live
in some areas of the world for little or
nothing because you know they just
there's not much there and so um you
know 75,000 would be living like 200,000
in the states in a lot of areas
agreed yeah it does make sense I guess
the question is we wanted to raise
Capital to start a business right should
we start a business on the mission field
on the mission field yeah to be very
clear yeah yeah then in addition to you
supporting you ask about qu raising your
family then you ask about not only
taking care of your family but in
addition to that taking care of your
in-laws and now we're going to start a
business so we're you know the more of
this we need we need more money if
you're going to go over there and say I
want to create some self- sustaining
Works uh by helping the people I'm
working with not only meet Christ but
also build a an economic model that they
can support themselves going forward
instead of living off of uh donations
from the states the rest of
generationally right I want to I love
the idea of sustainable works then then
you got to figure out how we're going to
fund that that's a third bucket do we do
we raise money on outside or do we have
$5 million saved and we're going to put
a million dollars into that and we're
going to use the other you know I don't
know how much you can save between now
and the time you go but um at the point
that your nest egg no longer will take
care of you and your in-laws because you
put it into that then I start to
question the wisdom of it um
because I do know that God said take
care of your own household first or
you're worse than unbeliever that's in
his word and so for your not for your
kids your family's needs not to be met
reasonably while you go do something
else is not
scriptural uh so we're we're going to do
it now I'm again you don't have to live
in a you know the the biggest house in
town or anything like that that's not
the point but uh but needs being met I'm
going to take care of my own household
the kids are going to be fed my wife's
going to you know have reasonable care
and so on uh with the numbers that we're
talking about and then we're going to
take care of the in-laws and then if
there's money left you can uh start
creating s some sustainable works and I
like every bit of that I think all of
those things are not only honorable
moral but I think they're excellent from
a spiritual perspective yeah all this is
the key word here is money and
prioritizing it in order of importance
and then once you've gone down the list
you can determine what it sounds like
the sustainable works is at the bottom
and that's going to determine what that
looks like you might not be able to do
you know a million dollar project but
whatever your budget decides yeah and uh
you know from a generosity perspective a
a good sustainable work is the easiest
to raise money for MH because people
that have money like putting it into
something that it doesn't just go down a
black hole that's right and you never
see it again yeah we want to create a
sustainable environment yeah uh where
the folks are are you know if I can buy
someone a cow and it feeds their family
forever I'd rather do that than buy them
a case of milk that's right you know and
so that that kind of a thing as a
generosity move when you're raising
money from people of means right which
is where you're going to raise money
from broke people don't have any money
to give so you know then they're going
to like the sustainability idea and um
you know the Ramsey Family Foundation
has invested in that several times I
mean we rice
fields so that they create feeds
families for Generations then in the
Name of Christ you know we bought we
have bought cows and uh in those
situations and so but all through
someone like a Graham who's on the
ground guiding that and drilling Wells
creat sustainability right that's
another sustainable move you know that
kind of a thing uh again versus just
sending buckets of water so to speak so
that that people love to give to those
kinds of things so it's easy to raise
money to get partners to come alongs
easier come alongside you to do that
than to um do the other things and all
of that can be a part of obviously the
EV Evangelistic move as well and they've
got 10 years to set this all up it
sounds like that's a lot of time yeah I
think you just got to keep your
priorities straight if it gets all
jumbled in your head which comes first
and you don't Force rank it you'll mess
it up this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can can completely change your space and
add value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's back by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now to get up
to 50% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
88255 225 just nine days before the
money and marriage getaway here in
Nashville Rachel Cruz Dr John will be
doing three days with you in every
detail of marriage including money money
and marriage every detail of money
including marriage there you go it's all
going to be there and with those two
it'll be fun oh they're funny and
they're entertaining and they're very
bright and it's going to be a great
weekend it's
$799 it's the entire weekend spent here
on our campus we're going to walk you
through a whole bunch of different
exercises you're going to leave with
your marriage strengthened uh in ways
you never even dreamed October 19th
through the 21st more Ramsey
solutions.com
events Travis and Briana are with us on
the debt-free stage right here in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions hey guys how
are you good hey Dave we're doing great
welcome where do you live we live in
Dawson Springs Kentucky it's just a
little north of Hopkinsville okay all
right very cool well welcome to
Nashville good to have you and all the
way down here with probably hour and a
half drive or so roughly give or take
yeah and uh to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off we have paid off
$777,500 wooo way to go how long did
that take took two years two years good
for you and your range of income during
that time it was $772,000 up to about
128,000 wow nice jump in two years
thanks so uh what do you guys do for a
living uh I'm a teacher M and I'm an
electrical engineer all right very cool
so what cost your income to almost
double in 2 years so we actually just
picked up a lot of side hustles so um
with me being yeah we picked up uh those
so I started tutoring uh peer tutoring
at my college um I'm working on my
bachelor's degree so that was an
opportunity for me and then picked up
some substitute teaching um and then
Travis had a lot yeah yeah I did um some
side engineering um outside my day job
and then and then I also did uh some
some residential house wiring I did U
mowing yards I did um piano lessons wow
uh flip stuff on eBay Facebook Market
place just all several things not much
time to sleep in all that you guys crazy
those side hustles sound like a
full-time job I mean that's literally
the equivalent yeah so what' you make as
a pure uh uh tutor um it was just about
$3 an hour they only let you work so
many hours a week because there's so
many peer tutors so yeah it was about
$13 an hour just out of all those
different side hustles that both of you
did I bet the engineering probably would
made the most right per hour right yeah
and then what was the next best one uh
mowing yards is great yeah it is it's
real good M yeah good money good very
cool what kind of debt was the 78,000 it
was just our house you paid off your
house look at it weird people look at
look at this house just popped it up on
YouTube nice how many acres have you got
it's about two acres a nice a lot to M
speaking of yard cutting look at you man
this just got even better yeah what a
beautiful place how long have you two
been married about 5 years God what's
house days around 200,000 look at you
man that's fun how old are you too I'm
23 I'm
29 and our house is paid for it's did
you see that house I saw it I saw it I'm
shook yeah these are these people are
weird I love it I love weird people way
to go you guys man normal's broke in
America and y'all ain't I like it very
cool so uh you've been married 5 years
but you've been on this journey to knock
off the house for 2 years tell us the
story how' you get connected to Ramsay
what what caused all this to happen so
um Travis actually worked at um a
previous plant and one of his co-workers
actually told him to start watching the
Ramsey YouTube videos and around then we
also had our daughter Elana so she is
almost 3 years old in January and I was
pregnant and then his plant actually
shut down so with it being the shut down
and then Co and all of the things we
were just a little bit more stressed
than usual so watching those YouTube
videos it just kind of got us wanting to
do more than just being ramish for the
first couple years of our marriage and
we started actually like picking up the
pace and getting on a budget and all
those things that we needed to do wait a
go wow yeah I mean Co plant shutdown
pregnancy all these things will wake you
up but all three of them together if you
don't wake up you dead
asleep that's pretty good that's amazing
my question is you know you're doing all
these side hustles I mean you just
listed a ton of them Travis that you
guys were doing were the people around
you thinking wow these folks have lost
their minds absolutely
absolutely yeah but but not the folks
that you have with you today right no um
so uh in that process uh we were wanting
some more tree leaders so uh we actually
started uh coordinating FPU at our local
church nice during that process so uh
all of these people have actually been
through that class with their parents
and my aunt and then uh even our smart
Vestor Pro he wanted to join along in
this so uh he come through too but we
have a team now we have a several people
in the church are with us I love that
wow start a class and that'll create
your own peer peer pressure group make
your own cheerlead if everybody's going
to gripe about it we're going to put
some people around that aren't yeah good
for you guys thank you for doing that
thanks for coordinating the class and
when you're doing the class you can't
really not do the stuff it kind of like
sets you up to be a hypocrite or be a
performer right yeah you got to get her
done so wow and your house is paid for
and your 23 and 29 that's so crazy know
my mind is blown awesome and you're
making 100 you know make have the
ability you're probably not going to
keep all those side jobs now but make
over $100,000 a year and you're in your
20s and you got nothing to do but stack
cash what's the first big thing other
than coming down here that you're going
to do to celebrate well um we we're
actually been in Nashville for this
weekend it's our fifth anniversary so uh
we we stayed through for a few days but
uh we're probably going to uh upgrade
the family vehicle you go do a few uh
upgrades to the home okay what's the
side hustle that you couldn't wait to
quit like that that the first on the
list Gotta Go I mean I worked pretty
hard doing all of them but uh I did
electrical wiring I would work my day
engineering job regular you know 9 to5
kind of thing and and then in the
evening I would wire houses a lot so I
would work till 9 10 p.m. and I'm I'm at
home wondering what my little girl is
doing and she's home asleep by the time
I get home and so that you know pushing
through that that's the first one to go
oh yeah it was hard on you it wasn't
hard on her she won't remember it no but
but she will know her whole family tree
got changed cuz her daddy wasn't hard
wasn't afraid of hard work I know that's
right proud of you man well done you
guys you guys are heroes you've set
yourselves up to win forever I'm so this
is awesome you're inspiring very cool
stuff hey we've got the live and give
bundle for you uh the baby steps
millionaires book Total Money Makeover
book Financial Peace University
membership you'll be able to give to
those to some of the people you're
leading and uh maybe enjoy the baby
steps Millionaire's book when you're
leading those
classes people ask how do you get out of
that what do you tell them the key is so
for me ours are a little bit different
so um I am the spender and he is the sav
so for me it was sticking to the budget
making sure you communicate and just
really try to stay on track with it the
every dollar app was really helpful in
tracking our expenses singing it to our
bank account so that was the key for me
personally and then the two of you using
the every dollar up to work together
that's a big deal yeah okay yeah she
calls me the nerd I I embrace it it's
okay
I like math it's all right I'm the nerd
at my house brother so it's okay so for
me um you know about about a year ago
last Christmas um Zach our adviser he
recommended that uh we could be uh
debt-free including our house come this
Christmas and we had a meeting with him
that year last year and we we were
talking about it we thought it sounded
crazy we thought it sounded impossible
and uh kind of blew it off and then
going through Christmas we're thinking
about it I'm running some math and you
know I'm putting the the the debt total
there and I'm trying to work it back
saying what would it take what if we
sold this what if what if we made just a
little bit more what if I picked up some
engineering stuff to increase my my side
income so so we realized well with a few
things it it actually is possible so I
said hey I'm going to start doing
engineering work two Saturdays a month
so I did that we had to start doing that
from January so from January to August
we actually beat the timeline because
you you'll find out as you start doing
this you get more excited that's right
and uh so Jun July June probably June
and July I worked every Saturday um and
we we paid it off in August cuz we were
so excited wow and now you didn't do
whenever you want mhm if you work like
no one else later you can work like no
one else
absolutely way to go you guys you're
amazing thank you all right Travis and
Briana do you want to bring Eliana into
the shot sure okay bring her up here for
the debt free scream they're from the
Hopkinsville Kentucky area 78,000 paid
off in 20 in 2 years 24 months making 72
to 128 the most side hustles I think
I've ever heard and Elana's had her
whole family tree changed and doesn't
even know it I love it count it down
let's hear a dead free Scream 3 3 2 1
we're de
free
yeah well
done
man
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped fam living
across all 50 states so see if chm could
be right for your family check out more
today at CH ministries.org
[Music]
budget
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Adam is in Springfield
Illinois hi Adam welcome to the Ramsey
show thank you sir thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up question
for you um how do we deplete our savings
SL emergency fund to F to pay off our
mortgage or do you work on saving up uh
while keeping that emergency fund there
to to build up enough to make a a final
payment to your mortgage the second
choice just go on and build up keep your
emergency fund intact and go ahead and
build up whatever that difference was
what is it 30,000 more that you need to
pay off the mortgage yeah our mortgage
is 39,000 right now at 2 and a half%
okay to start with we shouldn't have an
emergency savings fund we should have an
emergency fund and a savings fund is a
separate amount how much is in your
emergency fund not the
savings okay well we've got 20,000 we've
got 20,000 in in
savings that I've been saying our
emergency are four to six months okay
your three to six months is represented
about 20,000 is there other money in
that account other money in addition to
that
20,000 yeah yeah yes we've got a a
$2,000 emergency fund um and we've got a
I've got a pension with about 20 28,000
in it uh an imrf pension and my wife s
pension is about
250,000 so we don't want to use any
retirement funds and I think you meant
to say 20,000 in the emergency instead
of 2,000
right yes sorry yes sorry we have 20,000
in savings and not counting retirement
is 20,000 all you got yes okay 20 and
NOP 22 because we've got we've got a
$2,000 um as our you know emergency
emergency fund the $1,000 emergency fund
no the $1,000 goes away okay $1,000 goes
away when you're at baby step three
which is where you are you're debt-free
but you're home right correct okay so
you're you we don't have a $1,000
emergency fund anym that baby step one
is just until you're out of debt and
you're out of debt except your house so
now we have one emergency fund only that
is should be three to six months of
expenses what's your household
income we're sitting at about 140,000
okay then 20,000 is probably your
emergency fund mhm so you really don't
have any extra to put on your on your
mortgage out of that correct yes yes
then no you don't have anything extra to
put on your mortgage no no no you are
correct you are correct yeah okay so
we're not we're not going to do anything
extra on the mortgage because you don't
use your emergency fund towards paying
off your mortgage because it's not an
emergency right it's wise but it's not
an emergency people get tempted people
do get tempted to do that because they
go oh I only have this much left but
it's a bad choice yeah if you call me up
and you said okay in savings right
separate from
we have $80,000 of that 20,000 in
savings and I got 60,000 extra above my
emergency fund then I would say yes
throw that towards the mortgage and keep
the 20 in the emergency fund that's
right but um it's a good idea to not
let's just talk about this the reason I
was being so specific with him is I
learned a long time ago that people that
have savings accounts don't save
money because a savings account if you
don't have a system with it becomes
what's called a put and take account you
put it in and take it out put it and
take it out right until you put it in
it's a very large impulse account yeah
and so we put a bunch of money in there
and we buy a bass boat and we put a
bunch of money in there and we have an
emergency we put a bunch of money in
there we buy a couch we put a bunch of
money in there and go on a cruise now if
you've got your debt paid off and you've
got an emergency fund then you could
have a savings account you can have a
savings account but it does don't have a
vague savings account ever yeah it has
to every dollar needs a name name in
your budget and every dollar in your
savings needs a name I'm saving this
amount for the couch this am amount for
the cruise this amount is for
emergencies I don't have any
miscellaneous M impulse accounts because
they will do that they'll just that's
why that's why I don't you know I have
emergency savings account no you just
have an emergency fund yeah that's a you
know I think that's something that
Ramsey specific we do differently we say
you've got this money set aside it's
only for emergencies and that's it it's
not not to it's not a catchall is what
you're saying yeah because catchalls end
up with nothing that's right people end
up spending them all Jacob is in Detroit
hi Jacob welcome to the Ramsey
Show he Dave it's good to be on the show
thank you for having me sure what's
up um I was just wondering why you
recommend uh using mutual funds instead
of index funds well to start with index
funds are mutual funds they're a type of
mutual funds uh and why I don't
recommend using those
exclusively is pretty simple
um the there are about 40% of the mutual
funds out there outperform the S&P and
the typical when someone says index
funds are typically think talking about
an S&P 500 Index Fund are
you yes among others there's the Dow
Jones there's the NASDAQ and other like
that but there's Russell there's a bunch
of index funds but 90% of the time when
somebody call me talking about index
funds they've been reading about Bogle
and you know Bogle heads and passive
investing and Warren Buffett's advice is
just buy index funds which is not bad
advice an index fund will perform at the
stock market rate exactly I I own index
funds I'm not against them uh but but I
I do also own a whole bunch of mutual
funds that outperform the S&P and have
over 30 years so that would be why I
would do it does that make
sense yes just the fear that I'm having
is you mentioned the percentage of the
mutual funds perform better than
specifically index and I I want to be
the guy that wins and not the guy that
Li that gets lied to well what you L is
you look at a track the best shot you
got is looking at a track record the
only reason You' the only reason you'd
depend on the index fund is looking at
the track
record right if if we're looking at past
performance to indicate future it's the
only thing you have to indicate future I
mean if you have two funds and you know
when the commercials say that Jacob it's
absolute bull crap because think about
it how can you forast the future of an
investment other than by analyzing its
past and any changes that have happened
since that past
performance and the only way I can per
you know if I'm looking at a budgeted
area inside my company I use the last
three years to establish the budget for
the next year plus or minus any changes
that have happened since then right
that's called
forecasting and and to not use past
performance as a primary indicator if
there are no changes the only indicator
of future performance is is
asinine it's the only way you could for
how else would you forecast the future
on it
Jacob well we can look at the index
funds and they always exactly track the
market average exactly we can use that
as 100% you're still looking at you're
looking at past
performance that's what you're looking
at when you're looking at that and and
it'll always be true for index funds
just not other types of mutual funds but
you can look at other mut no no no no no
no no that's not true Jacob because
indexes are composed of five like for
instance the the the S&P 500 okay the
components of the S&P 500 have changed
over the years it's not the same
companies you know that
right right but it's still the average
and it's still the average of the top
500 companies but it's not the same 500
companies as it was in 1940 50 60 70 80
90 or 2000 or 2010 it's not the same 500
companies and so to use the index fund
and project that into the future as if
there were no changes is ridiculous it's
the only thing you've got though and say
okay it is going to track the market it
is representative of the market so the
only question is do I have a reason to
believe that a mutual fund I'll give you
an example one of them that is the
second largest mutual fund of all time
right now in terms of number of assets
has had an 85-year track record of
outperforming the S&P well crap that's
kind of a no-brainer man yeah you know I
mean if it's got a eight-month track
record of outperforming the S&P fine and
Jacob if you buy S&P and and you put 15%
of your income in it you're going to be
rich that's great so I'm not going to be
mad at you but to to do it on the to to
say don't recommend mutual funds because
40 60% of them don't outperform the S&P
and they don't bugle was right about
that Buffett is right about that but I
mean I can find in the other four out of
10 mutual funds out there that have a 85
or a 25 or a 50-year track record that
outperform the S&P and I'm going to end
up making more money than you're going
to make cuz the mutual funds make more
money than you make so but it's okay
we're both going to be rich I'm just
going to be richer that's all this is
the ramsy
show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsey Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episod
epodes download the Ramsey Network app
in your favorite app store
[Music]
today live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the Ramsey show
where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Jade
washaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at
88255 225 that's
5225 John is starting off this hour in
Chicago hey John how are
you doing well good what's up uh so I
was a sucker and I bought a motor home
when I got a uh remote uh job that paid
a lot more and of course I traveled all
all over the United States the last
couple years but uh I realized that um I
want to get out of B I want to get away
from that and of course I want to get
rid of the motor home and as that seems
to be hard without you know just trying
to sell it so I'm just seeing what my
options are what do you owe on the
mobile
home uh 70,000
and what's it
worth uh it's worth probably about uh
between 60 65 okay that's not too bad
you have any
money uh don't have much money how much
do you
have I had about 5,000 that I could put
towards it so you could close the gap
and sell
it yeah and and that that was my first
initial thought too um I had thoughts
about just letting go back to the bank
but I wasn't for sure what to do with
that no you don't let it turn it in
don't turn it in no here here's the
problem okay if it's worth 65 and you
voluntarily repossess it you're going to
have a repossession on your record
number one number two they're going to
sell it for 40 on the repo lot and
they're going to sue you for the
difference so you control the sale price
and you cover the difference you'll get
a lot more for it and you won't have as
much difference to cover or as much
hassle so now what you've got is the
hassle of selling a $65,000 $70,000
motor home which is a pain in the butt
to do but you can do it oh definitely
you can do it and it's a whole lot less
of a pain in the butt than having a repo
and having them chase you around for 40
Grand yeah because that's a funny thing
you say that because surrendering a car
or turning it in sounds a lot better
than repo but really what it is is a
repossession oh it's a voluntary
repossession and let me tell you if they
come and hook a recer and steal it in
the middle of the night or you take it
down there and hand them the keys it
shows exactly the same on your record
both are a
repossession okay so one's voluntary and
one's involuntary but the credit report
does not distinguish between the two and
uh people ask have you ever been
repossessed they don't ask have you ever
been voluntarily repossessed that's a
very good point Have you ever filed
bankruptcy yes period or no it's not
there's not oh well sort of there's not
a middle answer you did or you didn't
right and so that's that's the problem
with this and so yeah please folks sell
your stuff and cover the difference with
a loan sell your stuff and cover the
difference with cash uh control the
price of the sale of something you're in
the hole on that you're upside down on
like an RV I'm really shocked pleasantly
John that that thing's worth as much as
it is you must have put a lot down on it
to only ow 70 and it be worth 65 after
you've driven it around all over the
place well hey let me ask you a guidance
question because some people might be
wondering this that are listening let's
say you've got whether it's an RV or a
vehicle you're upside down and maybe you
found the cash to fill the Gap but it
requires you to do a personal sale like
you're going to for sale by owner yeah
that's fine but my guess the qu the
question I'm asking is how long would
you stay on sale by for sale by owner
before you would go to a dealership to
sell it or you know go through a
dealership well here's the thing if the
data indicates from Kelly Blue Book that
the car is worth $20,000 and you put it
on the market for $20,000 and it goes a
month and you get zero nibbles car's
probably not worth $20,000 yeah drop it
turns out KBB was probably wrong so the
car is probably 18,000 so you're going
to drop your price uh but the dealer is
going to give you 15 right so we can do
several series of price drops and reset
get resets until you get down to dealer
and if the dealer will give you 15 and
the Public's going to give you 15 then
I'll deal with you know it's worth it
you know that's the real price it's an
easier transaction to do it with a
dealer but it's very very seldom because
dealers if the car really won't sell for
20 mhm a dealer really doesn't want it
for 15 yeah because their job is to
resell it and make the spread yeah
they're buying to inventory to make a
profit on it and so they're not evil
they're not doing anything wrong but
they're buying it wholesale to sell at
retail and if you can't sell it at
retail they probably can't either I
think a lot of people avoid selling
their own vehicle because they're
thinking oh this is a hassle this is a
hassle something I've never done before
you know but we go to a side hustle and
we make a th000 bucks or we can go
through this Hassle and save $5,000 I
agree so yeah let's do the hassle hello
it's worth it it's worth it it's a it's
a nice part-time job to go sell your RV
right right you know it's um you set the
make a lot more on that than you will
deliver in Pizza I can tell you that so
Caitlyn is in Fargo hi Caitlyn welcome
to the ramsy
show hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve how can we
help um so I'm graduating this December
with my Master debt free um and I just
kind of want to be wise about income
that I'll be getting after I graduate
congratulations what's your Master's
in thank you and social work good for
you okay so what will you be
making um hopefully around 60 Grand it
kind of just depends where I get a job
um and I don't even know where to begin
with
investing okay and you're 100% debt
free I am yep no car
debt uh nope just pay off my car a few
months ago
okay you have an emergency
fund I do um I currently don't have a
job because I'm in college so I'm using
my emergency fund right now so the first
thing I need to do is build that back up
okay that's your first investment to do
and then after that depending on where
you're working I'm going to we're going
to say do retirement plans uh start
putting 15% of your income away for
retirement and uh then I would start
doing additional savings for purchase of
your first
home okay awesome that's pretty easy
pretty simple right there not much to it
you need to be on a budget and watching
what you're doing and um if I were you I
would want to get a head start on the
job
search okay because six months from
today you want to be working
there yes yeah that's hopefully the goal
yeah so I I'd want to know where there
is and what they pay and I can start to
do a little bit more planning that way
and you can find out how tough the
hiring Market is or isn't in that
particular category between now and then
I I'd want to be on that for sure
absolutely and you made a good point
there's always that question between do
I save for a house first do I start
investing first can I do them at the
same time that whole thing so I got a
feeling I just had the feeling she's
pretty careful yeah she's debt free 100%
education and everything MH so she's
probably a save for retirement and the
house at the same time and I she's
single so she's probably got that extra
ability to do that yeah you can control
that flow too yeah that makes a lot of
difference that's good very good fun
fune master's degree I love that yeah
love it well free pay debt free debt
free that's it yeah excellent good stuff
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
Dr John delon's book building a
nonanxious life has now been out for one
week you can get it at anywhere great
books are sold it will be a number one
I'm sure he is be a second number one
when we get this when we get the numbers
in in a couple days here and uh in the
meantime you can pick it up at ramsy
solutions.com there are six daily
choices to make to not eliminate anxiety
from your life but to greatly reduce it
and deal with it properly when it does
come your way everyone has anxiety about
some things anxiety is a good thing it
keeps you from running into traffic
right and uh oops Yeah Yeah I have
anxiety now yeah well don't run in
traffic you know it's a good thing so
you have to prep prepare your life build
your life in such a way that you have a
lower probability of living in it
perpetually and we've built such a crazy
world that now uh nearly half of the US
population reports their lives are
affected by anxiety stress burnout it's
everywhere building a non-anxious life
Dr John delon's brand new book ramsy
solutions.com Anna is with us in Dallas
hi Anna welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi hi what's up
so I do not need to get a car Lo but I
want to get one so that I could build a
good credit line and I was just
wondering what you would suggest how old
are you
Anna I just turned 20
okay why do you think it's important for
you to build a good line of credit what
do you plan to do with that good credit
score I plan I have somewhat of a credit
score just from like I have kept up with
like credit cards and such I only have
two and my credit stores is great but do
plan on buying a house so that I can
rent it maybe a duplex or even building
a duplex since I am in that industry and
I do plan on renting it out to people so
that they can pay for the mortgage what
do you what do you do in the real estate
industry I am an architectural designer
for a custom home builder okay very cool
um so all the talk about the credit
score so the ultimate use for you is
you're wanting to buy a house um we
actually teach a way that you can buy a
house without a credit score which is a
safer way to deal with money in general
because you're not having to enter into
debt in order to do the things that you
want to do you're not having to put the
risk of debt on your life and that
stress in your life in order to do the
things that you want to do so I would
say to you that if you have the money to
buy a car in cash buy the car in cash or
save up until you can
the idea of building up a credit score
and when you really look at what a
credit score is it's simply how you
interact with debt how long you've had
debt how much debt you've had uh what
percentage of debt that you're using
that's all that they're looking at
they're not looking to see if a person
can actually manage the money that they
have in their bank account in their
pocket does that make sense to
you yeah so what would you recommend for
someone like in my instance it's a
smaller bank so kind of more personal is
um like what would you recommend cuz I
know that I do plan on developing and
then building my own spec homes in the
future so I kind of want a relationship
with them if not I would have to get in
touch with some investors that I know of
let's talk about one let's talk about
one goal at a time because right now
you're like I want to do I want to do
this I want to do that that that and I
love the idea that you have goals going
to towards the future but the first
thought is your first thought is
ultimately how can I get a uh the house
that I want to get that was your first
question and so my thing is I'm going to
teach you how to do it without a credit
score so I would contact Churchill
Mortgage when the time
comes get let's get let's get that house
and let's get you living in a house that
you own before we start talking about
doing a speck house at 20 years old
right first things first yes sir okay so
I actually plan to live at home until
I'm married just to be more traditional
because I do plan on getting
married don't plan on having any bills
really until like I get the car if I do
it on a car
loan so I think that you should pay cash
for the car that's because you do you
understand you don't need a credit SC to
buy a house you understand that you've
been lied to you understand that it's
called manual under underwriting I did
it Dr John delone deloney did it uh
George camell did it we've all done it
so it's not just a theory it's manual
underwriting and all they're doing
you're walking through a lot of the same
process is they're just looking at your
actual money uh how much income you have
coming in as opposed to your debt that's
the only difference that's the only
difference so if I'm you I'm buying my
car in cash simply because I need a car
and then if you have any other debt I'm
clearing it up go ahead while you're
living with your parents save up 3 to 6
months of expenses not for your expenses
at the moment but what you think they
will be once you move out of the house
so you've got that ready moving out of
the house and living in an apartment
will actually help you get the will get
the though and here's the thing they're
not going to count your income like you
count it uh because they're not going to
count people that have zero expenses
because that doesn't exist in the real
world and so you know go ahead and
setting up your life as a young woman
independent woman is not a bad thing um
it's not an immoral thing either by the
way um but it does um it does cost more
money and you'll have your own space
your own place and um yeah I think
that's the direction I would go Courtney
is in Los Angeles hi Courtney welcome
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi guys thanks for taking my call
sure what's
up uh my question is should we sell our
home to purchase one that's bigger and
has lower monthly payments um but my
husband would have to commute about two
hours to work no no
way he's gonna hate that okay he's gonna
hate
you can I elaborate a little bit if I
may you can but I don't think you're not
talking me commuting 2 hours not a
chance I would do
that right no it wouldn't be an everyday
thing it would be so he's in law
enforcement so he has chunks of days
where he's working where he could be
staying with his mom and then on his
stretches of days off he would be
commuting up to us I don't like it I'm
just being honest with you you want a
part-time husband
yeah yeah I mean I'm kind of used to
solil Parenting with him being gone
honey if you want to do it you do it you
called and ask if we would do it we were
both unanimous in a no what did he say
when you when you guys have talked about
he lives with his mother instead of you
so that you can get this house what did
he
say um I mean he's he's open to it he's
very cautious we've looked at the area
and at the housing and it you know
everything looks good but we're just
doing a lot of thinking a lot of praying
I think you're prioritizing the size of
the house and the housing situation over
the quality of your life of your family
and I think it's a bad choice I'd agree
with that I agree I mean that's the way
she framed it up a bigger house in a
lower payment but I lose control of our
family relationships they're all over
the place you scatterbrain the whole
place yeah that's not a a chance not a
chance I live 8 minutes from my house
and there's no one there but my wife and
my dog but I'm still going home in a few
minutes wow that would drop me bananas I
couldn't do it in two hours I can almost
be in Knoxville Tennessee and is two is
it two is it two hours going and two
hours coming home that's 4 Hour oh no
way there life is too short for all that
yeah I mean I understand in Los Angeles
you're going to have longer commutes
than we have in Nashville sure we have a
better quality of life than you do
that's right but but just the same 2
hours is not it's not it's not
sustainable in the in a relational
context no for your kids your kids need
their dad more than that and and more
than they need their dad living with mom
part-time so you can have this house not
a chance yeah I'm not doing it no no no
no no no no so it's
um here's the other thing um if if both
answers suck you have you don't have
enough options if the answer that that
to our commute sucks and staying where
we are is super expensive sucks there's
always a third there you know what's the
what's another option there a fourth
option and a fifth option a sixth option
uh maybe maybe we don't live in that
area of California at all that's right
maybe he takes a job in law enforcement
in a different place uh that is more
affordable that we can live in uh I mean
you know maybe you don't make enough to
live in that area that's a fact uh and
so then you're forced into other
decisions people have done that for
centuries oh yeah in the United States
of America what causes people to move to
other areas uh all the time there's
always a migration in this country and
it a lot of it is driven by economics
mhm so um yeah that's a possibility but
yeah those aren't the only two options
in your life cuz both the options you
gave me suck you need more options this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America hey if you like this show we
would appreciate some help I want you to
subscribe click follow click subscribe
depending on whether you're podcasting
or you're youtubing or you're listening
on talk radio lock it in on your so you
can bring it up again at this time of
the day when your local station has us
click subscribe click follow also share
the show some of the services have a
share button that you can push and you
easily share the link and send that
around we'd love to have you do that and
of course the
um also leave a nice five-star review uh
and for those of you that didn't know we
are on this show is broadcast on TBN as
well and uh Jade I pulled up the TBN app
the other day and and you and Rachel
were on and it was beautiful yeah I mean
it really looks good y'all look great
and the show looked great and the
quality the delivery it's a crystal
clear it's a beautiful the set and
everything I didn't realize how good we
looked it's Prett Co we look pretty good
da nice stuff in the lobby of Ramsay
Solutions on the debt-free stage Mark
and Haley are with us hey guys how are
you hi great hey Dave how you doing
better than we deserve welcome so where
do you guys live Upland California cool
now where's Upland it's about 30 m east
of LA oh okay all right cool well
welcome to Nashville good to have you
and all the way across the continental
United States to do a debt-free scream
how much did you pay off we paid off
$474,000 I love it and how long did that
take about three and a half years good
for you I love it and your range of
income during that time we started at
174 combined and we ended at 296 look
wow what do youall do for a living
uh I'm a detective with the law
enforcement uh agency M and I work in
accounting ah very cool very cool very
cool so what kind of debt was the
$474,000 we had uh our mortgage yes you
paid off your house freaking LA on go
and the lady just called from La her
husband's in law enforcement and she
wants to move two hours away and you
just are sitting there shaking your head
listening to that you had to be feel bad
following that up oh man yeah with a
success story of how not to do it the
right way way to go what in the world
how long have you guys been
married going on 10 years M okay and
what's this house worth about a million
come
on
millionaires how old are you two 32 and
34 and you're millionaires yeah that's
crazy wow not I mean that's just with
the house we didn't even ask about your
Investments yet oh man what are those
how much in the investment
about 200,000 way to go guys you guys
way to go I'm so proud of y'all how's it
feel have no payments in the world
totally liberating yeah in California in
California and that the house was about
390 of that and then the rest we also
had a helck cuz we had an emergency HVAC
replacement MH and then two car
loans and solar panels or solar panels
oh man what happened three and a half
years ago what was the wake up call and
how'd you get connected to us so that
all came from a friend of mine at work
he uh I remember someone told me oh you
should talk to to vente he's paying off
his house and I thought someone had just
spoke to me in a foreign language so I
had to figure out what was going on so I
picked his brand he said it's Dave
Ramsey I said what what is
that I figured it was some magical
Bitcoin or something I could jump on and
uh he said no it's just hard work and
paying off your debt and having a budget
and I thought uh that didn't sound like
me and uh here we are three and a half
years later doing so he read The Total
Money Makeover book and then he pushed
me to read it it took me probably about
a month and then I read it and then I
was like okay I'm doing FPU so I ran
through that and then we were full steam
ahead wow okay so it goes from a friend
recommending it speaking in a foreign
language thinking Dave is a a
cryptocurrency that's the ultimate right
there I love it yeah that's perfect
and then uh you you get the book both of
you read it some somewhat force-fed and
then we go from that head long into a
Financial Peace University wow and you
did that on your own we did okay all
right very good congratulations you you
well done how's it feel to be completely
free you said it already liberating
liberating wow still unreal it still
hasn't like fully hit me at yeah I mean
and and it's kind of I mean at your age
you say I'm a milli here that just and I
don't feel different no you know it's
strange I still just I got to get up and
go to work it didn't change anything you
know it does have a nice ring to it
though I'll take it I love it I love it
so during this three and a half years
did you was this just taking extra
income you know from your normal jobs
and saying hey we're going to be
intentional about paying this off or did
you kind of put the pedal to the metal
did you pick up any extra hours he got
promoted during the time um and then
because he got a work vehicle we decided
to sell his truck so that was about a
little over $52,000 and we just put that
all towards the house because at that
way at that point we had paid off
everything else oh wow and then he
worked a ton of overtime wow yeah I
think I averaged at minimum about 40 to
50 hours every two weeks of overtime wow
on top of his 80 hours oh okay so yeah
y'all went hard in the paint very much
WoW hardcore so what can you get paid an
hour on overtime in that kind of situ
um so it's time and a half for us and oh
it is oh so it's not necessarily side
work as an officer it's not doing
something for the local church or
whatever that kind of thing it's it's
your actually overtime at the at the
force yes so ours would be there and
ours is more of like a medical transport
for inmates that are in custody and take
them to and from the hospital and back
to the facility okay wow there time and
a half o that's that's a lot that's not
bad that's that's a serious side hustle
right yeah cool yeah that that adds up
and you got a goal and you're getting
traction
so it the weird thing is is you're
you're tired but you're not burnt right
and I think the snowball really gave us
momentum I think we started small and we
progressed and we both felt that that
momentum start and it was like Hey we
got to get this done we're already this
is in progress and it's so close it's at
hand so let's get it yeah let's finish
it finish it finish it I like it well
done you guys I'm proud of you who was
cheering you on think each other we were
probably our biggest cheerleaders yeah
and Des santis s
yeah I'm sure is that his name is that
what you called it which your work Buddy
your work Buddy oh
vente not the governor of Florida right
okay I'm
sorry completely screw where did I go I
got screwed up there yeah okay he's like
what S is his last name he's like what
gu's running for president yeah but yeah
I'd love to just do a shout out to the
sented because honestly I I was I give a
lot of push back and I did not want to
go down this path and he every day he
would come in hey have you read the book
and I'd tell him no not yet I'm I'm
going to get to it and in my head I'm
like no way and then uh you know about a
month later I decided you know I'm going
to read this just to get this guy off my
back and uh next thing you know I'm
reading it I just this makes way too
much sense I don't understand how I
didn't know any of this before now yeah
I think you guys owe him a real nice
steak dinner oh yeah I think so you're
millionaires because of this guy that's
very cool yeah cuz he wouldn't let up on
his buddy you know that's good stuff
amazing very cool I'm so proud of yall
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt
is I think probably the budget is the
big thing uh you don't realize how much
money you're spending until you put it
down on paper and then it's like oh no
and then I think keeping each other
motivated keeping the angle in mind yeah
and uh yeah the little one right here
just go bring him in what's his name
this is rhs all right rhs is GNA he's
going to scream with us for sure we're
not sure if it's debt free but
he's that's good good you good job you
guys proud of you guys a little well
yeah he is yeah that's fun wiggle worm
baby steps Millionaire's book Total
Money Makeover book and Financial Peace
University maybe you can give it to one
of your other fellow officers and you
can be to them what your friend was to
you very good stuff we're going to send
all that with you congratulations we're
very proud of you guys you changed that
young man's life right there and he
doesn't even know it yet his whole
family trees changed his mom and dad are
millionaires baby steps millionaires
Mark and Haley and Rh Upland California
474 th000 paid off in three and a half
years making 171 to 296 house and
everything and baby steps millionaires
in their 30s count it down let's hear a
debt free screen all right 3 two 1 we're
dead
[Music]
[Applause]
free oh he'll be all right I promise
you this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
[Applause]
our scripture of the day Luke 14:11 for
all those who exalt themselves will be
humbled and those who humble themselves
will be
exalted a peacock that rests on his t
tail feathers is just another
turkey Dolly pardon of course you would
say that Dolly pardon well done you got
to love Miss Dolly all right Maryanne
it's it's like state law in Tennessee by
the way that's true uh Maryann is with
us in Richland Washington hi Maryann how
are
you I'm doing great thank you so much
for taking my call sure what's
up um my husband and I are in a bit of a
disagreement we wanted to find out how
much we should have in our emergency
fund as contract
workers okay okay are you are you uh
freelance or do you contract that
contracts have extended time on
them um I work as a travel ultrasound
tech and how long is your
contract 13 weeks they can be longer
than that though okay and what is the
probability of some kind of a renewal or
stepping into another one like 100%
right yes pretty high yeah that's why
you're willing to do that rather than
takeing a job doing it
right right okay what about him what's
his
contract uh well he's a welder so he
travels with me and then just gets work
in the area we're in and there's always
a demand for welders is there
not yes there is okay but his is his is
basically uh bit work it's um freelance
side work
right correct
yeah all right um well 3 to six months
of expenses is what we always say you
would be on the six month of expenses
side what are your monthly
expenses uh just typical rent no how
much groceries how much
money uh does it take for you to operate
your house in a
month I would say 4,000 okay six times
that what what was the argument
about well we're also still trying to
pay off my student loans no you're not
doing any you have A1 th000 emergency
fund then you don't have three to six
months of expenses $1,000 oh I
see does that make sense so even it does
so even if we like need a deposit for
our next rental when we
move why would you need deposit when you
move you get your deposits back do you
not typically we just started this this
year so typically the only reason you
wouldn't get a deposit back is if you
didn't fulfill the terms of the
lease okay yes I see if you don't tear
up the place and you abide by the lease
you get your deposit back
right yes yeah so typically would be
yeah you will period um and so that's
how you you arrange your Mo you you
don't sign a lease that's oh going to
say are you not a six Monon lease when
you have a three-month contract
right no we're just month to month yeah
okay good so you'd get your deposit back
you give them 30 days notice you don't
tear up the place and uh boom we're gone
so if you need to uh you know if you
need to if you're coming towards the end
of a contract and you think you're going
to be moving you would put into your
budget the deposits for the next place
because you're going to have to cash
flow those before the last place returns
them to you you're going to have a cash
flow bind but you're not going to ultim
Ely be out of pocket that money it's
just for a short you know like you may
be a month off you follow
me yes yeah so you got to prepare for
that but um how much is your student
loan
debt 37,000 cool yeah so for you right
now you're in baby step one you've got
the getting the ,000 saved and then from
now on until you get that $37,000 paid
off you're listing your debt smallest to
largest and your student loan is it one
loan or is it one loan broken to to a
lot of small
pieces uh broke into a lot of small ones
so probably right now your minimum
payment is satisfying the minimums of
all those little loans so you've got to
make the minimum payment to satisfy
those and then whatever money you have
left over you're going to throw out the
smallest of those little loans and
you've got to call in you've got to call
in and say hey I paid my minimum payment
but I've got this extra money here I
want it to go to this specific loan cuz
if you don't do that they're going to
take that extra payment and they're
going to divide it over all those little
loans again and you're going to wonder
well what happened I'm not seeing any of
the loan balances change so you've got
to call in to do that you have to make
sure it goes on that one smallest loan
when it's gone it's going to change the
it's going to get the that snowball
rolling for you so what's your household
income
Maran uh this year it was
130,000 okay then you should be dead
free in under a Year yay way to go
awesomeness thank you yeah way to go
you're doing great yeah it's good yeah
I'm not sure who won the argument but
you're doing great Johnny is in
Cincinnati hey Johnny what's up hey Dave
not much uh qu question for you about
Public service loan forgiveness and my
current student debt situation and
mortgage
situation so I have 96 payments on this
Public service loan forgiveness uh with
the goal being
120 for the program um I kind of had
that planned for since I graduated in
2014 didn't think too much about it had
a bunch of Life Changes take place and
now I have uh almost enough to pay off
the student loans and I'm considering
paying those off now instead of waiting
for the Public service loan forgiveness
well
yeah yeah did you say you graduated in
2014 correct so this is nine almost 10
years of just well maybe they'll do it
10 years of your
life yeah pay them off yeah not to
mention Johnny so here here's the
situation that so far
90 was it 97% of the loans that followed
the student loan forgiveness program
have not been forgiven they've only
forgiven less than
3% and so if you have a 97% % chance
that your plan's not going to
work the reason I
was I just told you three out of 100
don't argue with this three out of 100
it works for you actually think you're
one of those pay off your
loan right yeah right that's what that's
what I'm thinking what do you owe what
do you owe on it 86,000 I'd write a
check tomorrow hon I'd be free listen
you don't want to sit around and wait on
your on the government to make your life
awesome M because you're going to be
waiting the rest of your life and you're
going to be disappointed Yeah the secret
to happiness is low expectations lower
your expectations of what the
government's going to do for you because
it all amounts to nothing yeah 10 years
making minimum payments he could have
been done seven years ago well he's got
the money now so at today you know
either you're going to be sitting there
96 payments from now disappointed cuz
you're not one of three out of 100 that
actually gets the Forgiveness um or you
will have spent the last 10 years
Building Wealth because you got rid of
this crap by writing the check today so
the student loan forgiveness program is
a scam it's a lie anything that 97% of
the people don't get what was promised
to them is called a scam yeah it's a lie
it's a government lie okay another one
just like the Biden student loan for
forgiveness was it was a lie he knew it
was a lie he knew the Supreme Court was
going to throw it out and he played it
at the midterms anyway just to get
people to vote for Democrats it was a
lie we told you when he did it it was a
lie I've told you this was a lie so it's
a lie and the only Reas don't fall for
another Government lie democrat or
republican you can't wait on those
morons to fix your
life yeah and the thing is you're
hearing a lot more about it lately you
know you'll see somebody pop up my
student loan got forgiven and they're
doing these it's little popup
forgivenesses to try to keep people
hanging on the line right it's a lie
when you actually look at the
statistical evidence of the number of
people who got rid of their student
loans because of the government doing
anything it's almost zero you guys less
it's almost zero like you know one of my
buddy said the other day Biden forg $9
billion yeah out of 1.7 trillion on a
plan that already existed EXA it wasn't
him he just took credit for a plan that
was in place before he was in office
typical politic politics it's a
lie yeah God all right hope I'm through
now that puts this hour of the Ramsey
Show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the ramsy baby steps go to Ramsey
solutions.com and click the get started
button we'll help you figure out the
best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's Ramy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started